i'm going to talk about a truly
excellent paper uh entitled sdss4 manga
the g dwarf problem revisited
did you write this paper
as it happens i did yeah well
i saw that coming
to be fair it's actually the work of one
of my phd students guy called mick
greener and various of my colleagues
around nottingham and other places as
well but yes i'm one of the people
involved in this excellent conflict of
interest but we've dealt with it
yeah absolutely no no i'm hugely
conflicted but once in a while when
you're doing astronomy you find
something that nobody else ever knew
before and you just get that kind of
warm feeling about knowing something
about the universe that nobody else
knows it's it's why i do research oh
there we go tell me about what's going
on yeah so we need to talk about the g
dwarf problem first um which is as with
most things in astronomy a misnomer in
that it's not really much to do with
g-dwarfs and it's not really a problem
and to talk about it we need to think a
bit about star formation the simplest
picture that you could have of star
formation is you start with a big blob
of gas and it just starts producing
stars and some of them turn into stars
and of course if you started out with
just primordial gas are basically just
hydrogen and helium from the universe
that first generation of stars would
just be hydrogen and helium but pretty
quickly the most massive stars that get
made will blow up a supernova they'll
create some heavy elements from the
nuclear processes that are going on
within them and they'll start polluting
the environment with heavier elements
which means that the next generation of
stars that form start having some
heavier elements in them they'll then do
the same thing enhance the heavy
elements a bit more blow up the
supernovae and so on and so you have a
whole series of generations of stars
each one slightly more heavy elements
than the previous and in fact we don't
find any stars we can't find that first
generation of stars so few of them if
they even still exist compared to
everything that we find since that
actually you don't find any with no
metallicity no heavy elements at all so
i will keep referring to metallicity
that's
astronomers like to annoy chemists by
referring to everything heavier than
helium as a metal and so metallicity
just means the amount of heavy elements
in something the other thing that can
happen of course is if you just have
this simple picture of a kind of
isolated blob of gas so what's referred
to as the closed box scenario where
you've just got just this gas and
nothing else because you're going to run
out of gas and so you'll start making
stars and mic more and more stars but
then pretty quickly you'll have turned
it all into stars and there won't be any
more stars that get made one of the
things you can do is say okay so in that
scenario what kind of distribution of
heavy elements would you expect would
you expect to find lots of stars with
little heavy elements and not many stars
with lots of heavy elements or would you
expect to find very few stars with not
much by wave heavy elements and lots of
stars with lots of heavy elements in and
it turns out at least in that simple
picture you can actually just do the
calculation and the answer is that you
would expect to see lots of stars
without much by way of heavy elements in
them and the reason why it works out
that way is because you start turning
this gas into stars and so those first
generations of stars don't have much by
way of heavy elements in them by the
time you've got enough heavy elements
made to make stars with lots of heavy
elements in them there isn't much gas
left and so you don't end up making very
many stars that way so pictorially
there's a way of showing this
so here's a figure i was hoping for some
really cool three-dimensional box with
colors and gases but i've just no no
very simple you know this is a very
simple model so it's a very simple
calculation and this is basically saying
how much mass is there in stars that
have less than some metals of d z as a
function of that metallicity z and what
this is saying is that in this closed
box models of the blue line on here you
start making lots and lots of stars with
not much by way of heavy elements but
then you don't add many more stars at
heavier elements so you end up with a
curve that looks like that unfortunately
that's not what you see in the milky way
if you look at the milky way and in
particular the first place people looked
at this was at g-dwarfs this is why it
gets called the g-dwarf problem so the
sun's a g-dwarf it's not specific to
g-dwarf there are lots of g-dwarfs out
there so they're easy stars to look at
they are unevolved stars so they haven't
kind of stirred up all their own insides
they haven't generated lots of heavy
elements of their own what you see on
the surface of a g-dwarf is pretty much
what that star was made of so they're
good from that point of view and they're
bright enough to see a reasonable
distance away the picture we said is
what we naively expect is you'd expect
lots of things without much by way of
heavy elements in them and not very many
with lots of heavy elements in them yeah
what you find in the milky way is
completely the opposite so in general
stars in the milky way are more polluted
than you would have expected exactly so
the simplest way it turns out to fix
this is instead of having this thing
called the closed box you can have a
thing called an accreting box which is
just basically you start out with a
certain amount of gas you start turning
it into stars but as time goes on you
feed more gas in and it turns out that
fixes the problem naively you might
expect it would make things worse
because you're feeding in primordial gas
so this is gas which that hasn't been
polluted at all you'd think that would
actually end up making more stars with
little by wear pollution but actually it
turns out it has the opposite effect and
the reason is because your clothes box
is quite good at making the heavy
elements so you've got lots of heavy
elements around you just haven't got
enough mass around to make more stars
yeah and so the the accreted material
just kind of gives you the extra
material you need to start making those
stars with more heavy elements in them
more polluted stars so it's almost like
your closed box later in life is saying
i could make loads of polluted stars if
you just give me a bit more gas to make
stars with and it's like there we go
the box is now full of
fruit and currants it just hasn't got
any flour to make more cakes with
perfect yes so yes you've got all the
you've got the fun ingredients but you
just haven't got the basic raw material
to bulk it up to make stars with and so
that's what the the red line here shows
is just what would happen if you have
this accreting uh box model and it's you
can see it's doing the opposite thing
right the blue line where you didn't
have that material you made lots of
these stars with without much by way of
pollution in them and very few got added
later on here you can see you make fewer
stars without much heavy elements in
them but you've got plenty of material
at the end to make lots of stars that
have heavy elements in them and that
solves the problem for the milky way
right that actually if we say okay maybe
the milky way wasn't one of these closed
boxes we know it's not the closed box
because we can see things smashing into
it maybe just more and more material was
getting added to it maybe that's the
solution the neat part is we can now
kind of do the same thing in external
galaxies with this survey manga which i
talked about a bunch of times before
where basically we're taking spectra
across the faces of galaxies we can play
these clever games of actually splitting
that light up and saying okay we can see
the spectrum at each point in this
galaxy how much of that spectrum looks
like it comes from stars with high
metallicities intermediate metalistic
low metallicities so let me show you the
same kind of plot that we had before
but now for a whole bunch of galaxies
and we've kind of combined galaxies
together so the red line here is what we
find for the most massive galaxies all
the way up to the purple line which is
what we find for the least massive
galaxies all kind of average together in
those different masses and what we find
is that for for massive galaxies like
the milky way we had exactly the same
picture as for the milky way that you
need this accreting
box explanation because there aren't
very many stars
uh at low metallicity and there are lots
and lots of stars at high metallicity so
it looks like the milky way is
absolutely typical for its kind there's
nothing weird going on with the milky
way the more interesting thing though is
as we go down in mass and look at lower
and lower mass galaxies when you look at
the lowest mass galaxies which is the
purple one here there they look very
much like the closed box right that
actually there are lots and lots of
stars that are formed with these low
metallicity so the curve goes up very
quickly to start with and then we don't
add very many more when we get to the
higher metallicities so it looks like
low mass galaxies really do behave as if
they were kind of close boxes that you
don't actually have to keep adding mass
to a low mass galaxy to explain its
distribution of metallicities whereas
high mass galaxies like the milky way
you have to keep adding more and more
gas as the evolution's gone on surely
that's exactly as you would have
expected because a small galaxy is
probably less likely to be able to pull
in gas from other sources because it's
got less of a presence but you know
relative to its own size you know the
milky way might pull in 10 percent of
its mass because that's a big big lot of
gas but a little galaxy
will pull in you know also pull in 10 of
its mass so you might expect this thing
to kind of be scale invariant and they
all ought to behave the same way but it
clearly doesn't seem to be the case it
really looks like the low-mass galaxies
they've just had one load of gas and
that was all they got and they turned
that into stars whereas big galaxies
like the milky way have been fed
continuous stream of gas which has
allowed them to make more and more
higher metallicity stars although i
talked about you know adding gas it
could be that that gas was already in a
big galaxy like the milky way it was
already there it just wasn't forming
stars it was just kind of hanging out in
the outer parts of the galaxy and then
you know as the star formation was doing
its thing it would then start feeding it
in whereas little galaxies it looks like
all the gas is involved in star
formation all the time which is another
way of saying that it's much better
mixed everything's all mixed up so that
actually there isn't one load of gas
over here which is not forming stars and
a load of gas over here that is forming
stars it's all all forming stars and all
churning together professor i don't know
if it's because we're in lockdown but at
the moment when we're talking about this
all i'm thinking about is like you know
ingredients and and sultanas and flour
and bakeries and things like that maybe
i've made too many cakes in the last
week or two when you lay in bed and
think about this stuff you know
are you i what scales and time scales do
you think obviously you're not thinking
about it on galactic time scales because
you'd have to lay in bed for 100 000
years or something but like
how do you imagine this stuff when
you're lying in bed are you imagining
all the graphs and the mathematics are
you imagining the objects and things
falling in but just in fast forward like
what does that look like inside your
head when you think about this when you
look at one of the simulations on the
screen right where you see the whole
thing nice and small and in fast forward
you see it in your head as happening on
human time scales but then you just have
to take that step back and say but
actually that process is taking hundreds
of millions of years not a few seconds
to be honest the the main time i stop
and get awed by it is when i talk to you
or you know when i give a popular talk
or when i'm trying to explain it and
suddenly you do have to take that step
back and it's no longer you know that
one with all those zeroes that i just
take for granted suddenly you've got a
whole bunch of people saying well that's
an amazingly big number and then you
have to take that actually you're quite
right it is an amazingly big number
there's also something about it though
when you think about the reality of the
size and more the time scale
while it is more awesome it sort of
becomes more boring
is that fair like it's almost like you
think well yeah that looks cool in a
simulation but in fact that's just
happening at something that
beyond glacial like it's all just
happening so slowly isn't that amazing
in itself i think that's amazing that
this this majestic scale of this thing
right it's not you know it's a huge
symphony that's going on it's not some
little tune
and actually the time it takes to unfold
is enormously long
i think that adds to the beauty of it
not detracts from it it's all right if
you've got long enough to sit around and
watch it but come on we're in a hurry
here
but that's the neat thing right isn't it
amazing that we can actually start to
understand things which take hundreds of
millions of years to happen it's quite
amazing that a human mind which as you
say is kind of focused on things
happening on time scales of hours
can actually comprehend things which
take
billions of years in some cases i think
that's pretty amazing really
they use the super protons synchrotron
collider at cern
they had a beam of electrons of about
100
gv
of these lego bricks
represent 100 kilometers on this map to
put some things into scale first let's
talk about airliners so when we're on a
commercial airliner